Taylor Swift and Maddie Healy Calling it
Quits I have to understand that like
there are incredible perks that come
with this life they're also really heavy
pressures that come with this life and
you just have to try to balance them
et's learned the rumored couples ended
their brief Romance
[Music]
a source tells E.T Taylor and Maddie
broke up they are both extremely busy
and realized they're not compatible with
each other
ET Source adds that Taylor's friends
want what's best for her and aren't
shocked that their relationship fizzled
out since she recently got out of a
long-term relationship I mean I think I
feel things intensely fans began
speculating about their breakup Friday
when Maddie returned to an old habit
during a show in Denmark
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah Maddie's been known to lock lips
during his performances
[Music]
[Applause]
yep definitely giving single Vibes I see
my life
hopefully getting to a place where I can
evolve and change back in April Ichi
revealed that tay ended her six-year
relationship with Joe Owen then in May
Maddie Healy was spotted at Taylor's
era's tour stop in Nashville that's so
good A source told ET at the time they
like each other and are having a good
time hanging out Taylor has a crush on
Maddie and he thinks Taylor is awesome
and Incredibly talented you never know
what it's going to be though Taylor
normatty's commented on where their
relationship stands one thing's for sure
these two know how to keep them guessing
I would always like to keep people on
their toes in that regard I think that's
the best way to be exciting
[Music]